so for starters I want to thank you all
for joining in today and I'm really
looking forward to going through this
with you this is the first of a five-day
stream course if if you've seen the
course that I did earlier I'm gonna try
to not follow that exactly so I'm gonna
go I guess a little bit off script and
it's still a beginner intro to
developing skills so if you haven't
built any skills before no worries
hopefully we'll be able to to walk you
through that for the the earlier
question yeah we're gonna be working
with nodejs and javascript but I'm gonna
go through it hopefully in a way that if
if you're not a JavaScript person it
will still make sense to you
for starters any I'm gonna try to look
at the the comments I've been building
skills for a little while but the
streaming live streaming this is totally
new to me so like this is literally the
second time I've ever extreme Denny
thing and the first time was like this
morning so so if I screw anything up let
me know and I'll try to fix it put it in
the comments I I've been on a lot of
live streams like on the other end of it
so I'm trying to follow some best
practices or some things that I've seen
on other streams that seem to work so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna talk for
a little bit and then I'm gonna pause
and look at the comments to try to
answer any questions so as I'm going
just ask questions and I'll try to from
time to time look back and forth so I
want this to not be a lecture where
you're just sitting there watching my
screen I do want to try to make it
interactive but at the same time I want
to cover a lot of ground in a pretty
short period so try to balance that like
I said earlier this is going to be a
five-day livestream so we're gonna start
1 p.m. Eastern every day for the next 5
days and it's about 30 to 45 minutes is
what I'm planning I've got an hour
booked mostly that is for mistakes and
so a little bit of offer there but
probably 30 to 45 minutes per day and
the goal is hopefully by the end of this
to have a completed skill bill while
talking through what's happening along
the way so again so you not just
watching me code I want to talk through
it and make it make sense and answer
questions as we as we go so is if you
can like just make a quick comment are
you I'm sure there's probably a way to
do like a poll or something but I don't
know how to do that so I'm gonna just
ask do you how many of you are building
skills right now have built a skill or
just like completely brand new to it
where if you and if you are that's fine
I mean that's if you're brand-new and
never done any of this before that's
cool if you build some skills before
that's great too if you've got any
specific questions just trying to get a
tally of where everybody is so I can
adjust the the topic hopefully
accordingly to that so just read quickly
through the questions store variable
persistence okay all right so let me let
me let me start at the beginning so to
to follow along with this minimally
you're gonna need two things you're
gonna need a in AWS Amazon Web Services
account and if you don't have one of
those you can get one at aws.amazon.com
and this is a paid service in case you
know that but they do have a free tier
and the free tier is pretty generous
there's I think you get like I want to
say like a million requests yeah like a
million requests for land and that's
what we're gonna be using the lambda
service so you'll if you want to follow
along or do what I'm gonna be doing at
your own pace you will need to have an
AWS account you also need an Amazon
developer account so to get that you go
to developer guide Amazon
and I'm logged in but so from here you
would just sign in or if you don't have
an Amazon developer account you just
sign up and if you have an Amazon echo
you don't need one to do development but
if you have one you want to use when you
sign up for your Amazon developer
account you want to use the same email
address that you used when you set up
your echo because that will let you test
your skills in development mode without
really jumping through any hoops and it
just makes things easier so use whatever
email address that you use for your echo
when you sign up your developer account
if you're doing that so with those two
things you're ready to you ready to get
going
building a skill you can do everything
from the web browser which I'm gonna
walk through really quick first just is
it's kind of a reference point for where
to get started but as we get into
building our skill over the next few
days I'm going to transition from the
browser stuff into doing the development
with some local tools so
IDE and the Alexa skills kit CLI turn
Alex off here and and I'll talk about
what those are and the the advantages
pros and cons and using one versus the
other and all that good stuff so for
starters the starting point the
jumping-off point would be the developer
portal for sure so developer amazon.com
and if you go to the Alexa section of
the portal the documents we're gonna be
there's sort of two areas when you're
building skills there's the the Alexa
voice service and the Alexis skills kit
so the skills kit is for building skills
which is what we're going to be talking
about over the next few days so building
skills is kind of analogous to building
it out so skills make alexa give alexa
capabilities that are not there right
now so I guess effectively making her
smarter it's smarter depending on
your your preference for that and the
Alexa voice service is for Alexa
enabling devices or software so if you
wanted to put Alexa into some smart
device you can do that which
incidentally like you you here on the
smart device you hear reference like
smart speakers and I'm going to take
just a second to just talk about how it
all works it's actually the the device
itself is really not all that smart all
the smarts are in the cloud in the Alexa
service and so the the device itself is
really just kind of a terminal that will
listen for the wait word which is Alexa
and then stream what it hears when it
hears the wake we're back to the the
back end service and then from there the
Alexa service is going to convert the
voice stream to text and then we're
going to set up an interaction model
which I'll talk about more a little bit
later that is going to hopefully tell
the Alexa service what the user wants
and then we can handle what the user
wants in our skills service which is
something else that we're going to talk
about a little bit later but let's start
here so to create it I'm gonna walk
through creating a skill just really
really quickly like super basic and then
talk about the the step so I'm gonna
hold off on answering any questions for
just one second here while I walk
through and just kind of show you high
level what um what goes on when you're
creating a skill so after you've signed
up and logged in to the Alexa developer
portal you would go to your Alexa
council and in your skills and then here
I'm using a fresh account so that you
can see everything from the beginning
and you would just go create a skill and
give your skill a name and I'm gonna
call this one
free code camp and create skill and
these we're gonna be creating a custom
school there's a few different types of
skills there's like flash briefing
skills and video skills in audio player
skills but the the custom skill really
gives you the most control and that's
what we're going to be going through in
the in this livestream and over the next
few live streams so once I have created
a skill it pulls me into the skill
configuration area and from here so this
is where I'm gonna configure everything
that's basically going to allow the
Alexa service to recognize what a user
is invoking the skill or starting the
skill up and then requesting
functionality that the skill should
provide and that's all going to be done
through creating something that's
referred to as an interaction model
which is really at the end of the day
adjacent document you know so or this is
the this is a very starting point so we
can do this graphically and it's going
to create the the Jason for us or we can
just write the JavaScript object
notation which is the Jason syntax in
here but we'll get into this in a a
little bit I'm gonna just going to step
through like I said a really simple
example so right here is the the first
thing which is the invocation name and
the invocation name is the name that the
user is going to use to start the skill
up or to invoke the skill so this is
different than the skill name the skill
name is what users are going to use to
find the skill when they're searching
through the skill store and it they're
often the same generally the same they
don't have to be though the invocation
name can be different the invocation
name during development can be pretty
much whatever you want it to be however
and we'll we will
I'm gonna try to submit a skill for and
I'm gonna try to do this tomorrow I you
know try to get a skill done that we can
send to through the approval process and
hopefully it'll be back by Friday it's
usually pretty quick but maybe it'll get
kicked back and that'll give us an
opportunity to talk about that but the
invocation name is important especially
when you're submitting the skill for
certification so that it can be
available to the world and there's lots
of guidelines around what you can and
can't do
with regard to the invocation name and
so you can read about those down here
like you can't use single words and you
know words that are used as part of
Alexa's native functionality and and
some other things but we'll we'll see
that I'm gonna just for right now call
this three code camp so I'm gonna use
the same invocation name as the as the
skill name so now to start this up we
would go like Alexa opened free code
camp and that would start it up or Alexa
asked free code camp something so the
the interaction model is made up of a
few things it's made up of intense which
are intense or a reference to
functionality that the skill provides so
in it's pretty granular it's kind of
analogous to like a function in encode
but not exactly so if for example if you
had a skill that was for ordering pizza
you might have an intent called
order pizza and then the purpose of that
intent would be to take the order and
confirm the order with the user but to
fulfill the intent you might need to
collect a whole lot of information from
the user so in that example of a pizza
delivery you
it also need to ask them what size they
want ask them what toppings they want
maybe get their address but payment
information and that back and forth is
referred to as a multi turn dialogue and
so there is also dialogue management
that happens or is defined inside the
interaction model and then what you're
trying to get to process or fulfill the
intent is the information that you need
so in the case of ordering a pizza the
topping you might need the value for
topping which would be maybe pepperoni
or onions or olives or whatever and the
the parameter values the variables I
suppose those are referred to as slots
and so we've got in the interaction
model three things we've got intense
we've got slots and we've got dialogues
and we'll dive into this in more detail
when we get further into building our
skill but you can do this all
graphically so you don't need to you
don't need to write code to do this you
can do this through the the web
interface so if you wanted to create a
custom intent like hello intent I would
do something like that and then a tenth
intents are recognized so the when a
users asking Alexa to invoke your skill
and then to have your skill do something
you provide sample utterances to let the
Alexa service know what the user might
be asking for and so I'll say hey hello
hi and you provide some examples like
that all the Alexa service is pretty
smart so with a handful of examples it
will start also or be able to start also
inferring some things so you don't need
to provide every possible scenario would
you want to provide enough where the
Alexa service can learn
generally what it is that that you're
doing so in this case here this intent
if we go look at the Jason editor how am
i doing on time 16 after this intent is
you can see now written here to the
Jason I've got my hello intent there
right now it doesn't have any slots but
it's got some sample utterances so what
this is telling the Alexa service is
that when a user says hi hello or hey
that the intent that is going to be tied
to code that's going to provide
functionality later is the hello intent
okay so hopefully that makes sense I'm
going to come back to this if it if it
doesn't but I want to move through this
stuff pretty quick so we can get into
the coding part so like I was saying
earlier when a request comes in it
happens the user makes or talks to the
device says the wait word the Alexa
service is going to identify based on
the invocation name which skill the user
is wanting functionality from and then
based on the utterance what intent they
are trying to get done and all of that
information is then sent to a service
for processing so like a back-end
service an API and that's something that
is developers we've got to create and
that is referred to in the the developer
portal here as the endpoint so the
endpoint the Alexa service is going to
collect the request and then send the
request off to our service for
processing and then our service is going
to respond back with the information
that the user is looking for hopefully
so there's two different two different
ways you can go at this you can use an
Amazon or AWS lambda function or you can
use any HTTP endpoint so it really it
really doesn't matter how you process
the RIC
as long as you're sending back Jason in
a format that the Alexus service can
understand and as long as your service
is able to understand and process the
request that's coming in and the
requested response formats that the
documentation is really pretty good I
think anyway for for the the Alexa
development stuff the the confusing part
is probably more in the the SDK which
I'll talk about later because it's kind
of a wrapper for what's really happening
under the hood under the hood it's all
pretty simple the Alexa service is going
to send a request to your skill service
in a format that is going to be Jason
like this and your skill service needs
to take that in read what's happening in
there and determine based on that how to
respond and it's going to respond with
adjacent response also so it's just a
conversation that's going back and forth
between the Alexa service and your skill
service that is that is pretty much all
that's going on it can get complicated
as you get into the development or not
complicated but involved I suppose but
let me let me continue on here and I'm
gonna try to like yet in about five
minutes pause to to look at the
questions so the like I said you could
use anything we're gonna we're going to
use a lambda function for this and
that's definitely the easier way to do
it or at least in my opinion and the
recommended way to do it is lambda
functions also so I'm gonna on the
endpoint here I'm gonna select the AWS
lambda a RN and a RN is the it's an
acronym for Amazon resource name you can
copy that to the clipboard and then I'm
gonna head over to AWS and I'm gonna
sign in
and go to lambda and so the first time
you go in here you would just go create
a function and this has changed a little
bit there's actually a couple of
different ways to do this just for
getting started so you can create a a
lambda function from scratch and that's
fine except for in most of the examples
that you see out there when you go to to
github and or a lot of the documentation
the examples the code examples are going
to be using an sdk and that is something
that you can find at github calm slash
alexa and the there's a new one for
python i think i saw recently i know
there's one for java but the javascript
one is the most popular one right now
and it's been out for a little while so
there's lots of code examples although
it was recently updated from version one
to version 2 and version 2 is
significantly different than version one
and so if you're if you're doing
development and you've already gotten
into this I'm sure you you've seen that
I've got a lot of other tutorials if you
go to my dabba lab YouTube channel and
so there's a couple other people from
data lab on here so if you have any
questions they can try to ask to Ken and
Arpita are on the chat as well but the
the dabba lab YouTube channel at
youtube.com slash data lab and so some
of the as I'm going through this I might
reference some tutorials that I've
already done just to to save us time and
get through it quicker but the the
change from the 1.0 to the 2.0 SDK
everything that we're going to be doing
this week is going to be with the the
later SDK to Daddo
and so yeah where I was going with this
was if you create a function from
scratch it's not going to include the
the SDK and so you would literally need
to be writing back from that function we
you just need to manually write code to
write back the the Jason response and
you can I mean that works for a really
simple skill like a very very very very
basic skill actually I just show that to
show you that so I'm gonna do a simple
example and you just give your your
lambda function a name like this and
then choose a role I can't remember I
set this up or not
yeah so if you have an existing role
yeah I do a lot so let me see if I can
create a custom role this is what
happens the first time if you're just
getting into this like it'll pop you
through this process like create a
lambda basic execution role it's
probably gonna scream at me and say I've
already got this no here we go okay so
so you create a role in a role is
basically permissions to allow the
function to run and then you go create
function but before I do that the
blueprints and service service
application repository the blueprints
are like the name implies kind of ready
to go templates of sorts that you can
use and they're not just blueprints for
Alexa there's blueprints for all kinds
of stuff but the ten that the the trend
now is that everything seems to be
moving over to this serverless
application repository templates and
these are cloud formation if you're if
you're familiar with the Apatow
basically templates that define how the
backend should be set up and and I'll
I'll show this a little bit later
because it's kind of useful for for some
things but just for our very first one
we'll just start from scratch and then
create a function and then in here
lambda functions are there to really I
like them a lot there
they're great in that they let you just
focus on writing code without having to
worry about configuring the server and
all of that stuff they work differently
if you're used to building web apps and
maybe using nginx or whatever web server
Apache you prefer where you set it up
and it's sitting there waiting for
somebody to make a request
that's not how Landa works the way that
lambda works is it's sitting there doing
nothing not running at all which is good
news for you because you don't pay if
there is nothing happening it's just
sitting there waiting and it's waiting
for a trigger so for an event and the
there's different Amazon services that
you can use to to trigger a lambda
function in our case we're going to be
using the Alexa skills kit and the Alexa
skills kit is or adding this trigger to
the lambda function is what's going to
allow us to use this lambda function in
as the endpoint for our for our skill if
you don't see the that option the Alexa
skills kit over here for some reason it
might be because you're in the region
that doesn't support it and so you just
go up here and change to a region that
does support and I'm not sure which one
is doing don't honestly I think all of
the US ones do I'm pretty sure but if
you're not sure I know US East does so
you can just select that one if you want
to go through it and then this isn't
required but it's good practice the the
configuration required here so the skill
ID verification basically prevents any
other skill from using this lambda
function so you basically paste in the
skill ID if you guys remember when I set
the skill up in the developer council I
copied that to the click the clipboard
so that was from right over here and and
you paste it in there and you choose add
and then save and then
the way that I'm gonna tie this to the
skill is with this AR n so this Amazon
resource name up here and this is the
kind of the unique identifier for the
endpoint and then I'm gonna go back over
here and paste that in here and and then
I'm gonna save this so and let's see so
now see the endpoint all right now save
the model and build the model so
building the the model this is gonna
take a minute so while this is building
I'm going to go work on the the code
over here just to show you so the what's
happening right now when you're building
the model it's basically using the
information from our interaction model
to train the alexa service the machine
learning behind the alexa service on
what to do and so we'll let that
continue but over here like right now if
i if i run a test on this the response
format like i mentioned earlier it needs
to be in a format that the alexa service
can can understand and so i'm gonna do
one like without using the SDK let's see
if I can just I was talking about the
request and response
oh wait there it is so I think like the
simplest possible
Alexis skill would be something like I
don't even need all this but actually
[Music]
I think they thought I'd saw one in here
yeah here's one
[Music]
I'm gonna just hack this up real real
quick just to make it respond with
something and with all this directives
and we prompt so you can see it is just
Jason you need this I think this is
probably like the most basic possible
skill service we'll see if it works
no guarantees but I think it will open
speech plain text say hello yeah so this
would give you an example of just kind
of what's happening under the hood if it
works I haven't messed anything up so
this is all built so now if I go test
this what I call this free code camp you
just enable testing here I'm back in the
developer Council and I can just say
like open free code camp and I get null
so there was a problem with the skills
to response and that is because I am a
syntax error
[Music]
which i think is where oh wait that
looks that looks good all right let me
see what's going on here okay
I am missing something simple okay let
me see just paste all this in here oh
you know what I forgot to return this
[Music]
[Music]
yeah so this is why this is why you use
the SDK then I can get rid of all this
[Music]
okay let's say that try this again okay
so now I'm getting a response back and
this is the simplest skill service ever
so save that and this is returning like
the most basic response that the Alexa
service is going to to understand and so
I can play it here although I've got my
sound turned off but let me turn on the
my echo Alexa open free code camp
all right so I'm gonna I'm gonna pause
here it is 31 35 and just look at the
the questions so real quick to recap we
set up the skill service in the
developer portal and then I set up a
really or the the skill set up the skill
in the developer portal and then set up
a really simple skill service that is
just responding with a minimal response
that the Alexus service understands and
in this case all of this skill is going
to ever do is just say hello there no
matter what the user passes over but
this this kind of shows you what's
happening under the hood so this is the
request that's going out from the Alexa
service to my skill service which is the
land of function and then that little
bit of code there is just responding
with with this here which is what's
getting sent back to to the user okay
let me let me take a look at the
questions here
okay - I'll ask you all a question does
that does that make sense sort of the
the back and forth between the alexa
service and the skill service is just
start there
so one said what's an Amazon elect skill
development building skills for Amazon
Alexa which or the the Alexa service
can you let me know see ya Maria the the
the video will stay up so you can watch
it another time yeah Nicholas I was I
was just not even returning the the
Jason at all when that land up function
so I made it I made it harder than it
needed to be
familiar with node that's good
Congrats Ryan got your first job offer
that's awesome yeah Wayne as we as we
get into building the skills so that the
skill that I'm I was thinking of for for
the rest of this stream so not just
today again I'm gonna be streaming for
the next five days and it'll be about 30
30 minutes to an hour starting at 1:00
p.m. Eastern and over the five days
we're gonna build a skill and the the
skill that I was thinking of is like a
and ask me anything skill so this is the
the idea that I had was a skill where
you could basically have a list of FA
cues that a user could go ask questions
and get answers to but I was also
thinking it would be really cool if
there was a way for the user to ask a
question that hasn't already been asked
and so how I was thinking we could go
about that maybe is the user would ask a
question and then the question would be
saved to a database and I'm thinking
like DynamoDB and then somebody could
review those and it answer the questions
and make that a part of the the FAQ or
the ask me anything so sort of a voice
version of it asked me anything if
you've seen those on github where
they're just basically a repository for
questions that have gotten asked and
answered so that is the skill that I
think we will be building yeah or
planning on building so what else we got
okay I'm gonna so that is a that is a a
really that's a really simple skill
without using any of the the SDK stuff
let me show you a another way to go at
it and this is I'm gonna go back and I'm
gonna create a different function
different lambda function and I'm gonna
call this one SDK example and yeah
choose an existing role that land a
basic execution role and this time I'm
going to use a blueprint and the
blueprints the blueprints are like
boilerplate code or example code that
Amazon provides and there's what I'm
going to use this one here this no js'
Alexa skills kit and this one is space
packs and you can see this one provides
some code that we can edit here and this
is a skill that is provides well spaced
facts so these are you can ask give me a
fact and it provides like a random fact
about space and same thing here remember
we've got to add the trigger the Alexa
skills kit trigger and I'm gonna go back
over here and we're gonna change this
skill service to point to this new
lambda function so I need to get the
skill ID again to do that coming back
over here and go to the endpoint and
then copy the skill ID again to the
clipboard
and then the configuration information
down here I'm gonna paste it in and then
add that save this and now I need this
new AR n so I'm going to copy that and
just replace this with that and then
save the endpoint
and then if I go test again now I won't
turn on my sound so you can hear this no
not that's gonna just play that so okay
so now you see I do testing in here and
you could have I'm also I've got the
video playing just to monitor it for the
comments so I don't want to turn on the
sound is picking up on the the mic it'll
just loop but you can see here here's
your fact the Milky Way galaxy will
collide with the Andromeda galaxy in
about five billion years let me try it
Alexa open free code camp okay so same
same thing happening behind the scenes
that the big difference between between
this and the last lambda function is
this lambda function is using the Alexa
skills kid and it's using the Alexa
skills kit 2.0 which you can see in here
if and I'll talk through this as we get
into it more but the it's requiring this
Alexa SDK and so a lot of the creating
the response back to the Alexa service
and more specifically creating the the
Jason that gets set back is handled by
the skills kit so it just makes writing
the code a lot simpler and but still the
same things happening so if I if this is
the request that's coming over and this
is the response coming back if I were to
go over here and test this
I could do I could paste in so I just
this I just copied from the test council
in the developer the developer console
and then launch request naming it here
and then create and then I can test here
and I can see the response back down
here so this is this is at the end of
the day what we need to do we need to
generate a JSON response and that's what
the skills kits gonna help us out with
but when you when you look at a lot of
the the code examples out there like I
was mentioning earlier there's a lot of
a lot of examples that use the 100 SDK
and the code is is quite a bit different
with the the - data SDK still JavaScript
so if you're familiar with JavaScript
it's not super hard to to work through
but if you're just getting started with
with JavaScript just be aware the
difference between the 100 and the 200
code so when you're looking at code
examples you'll you'll know if it's one
or two so any any questions about that
up to this point I think we're gonna
probably call it a day on the coding
side the first goal was just for today
to walk through the the high-level steps
which I think we've done and tomorrow
we're gonna get into talking about
planning the skill that we're gonna be
building and get kind of a rough
framework of that skill built tomorrow
and maybe even enough to submit it for
certification and then we'll add
functionality to it
on Wednesday Thursday and Friday and
hopefully finish up on Friday but any
questions about what we've what we've
covered to this point let's see how do
you add addresses from a JSON file to
the Alexa developer portal or is there a
tool to deploy that from code yeah there
is Parimal there
is the the ask s the ask CLI so I'll get
into this later in the week but when you
when you start building skills that are
a little bit more involved or actually
not even a lot more involved you you'll
probably want to use the Lexus skills
kit CLI and the alexa skills kit CLI and
i'll show you real quickly ask new this
is the CLI doing this lets me create
code that I can deploy from my local
computer so this example skill this is
called a skill project and then the code
for our lambda function is in here also
and I can modify this code and you can
start with templates I've got some other
tutorials on the Dabba lab youtube
channel that use templates from skill
templates comm which is the site that
that we set up it dabba lab mostly for
ourselves because when we start new
skill projects we start from code that
is kind of boilerplate code and so we've
got some basic skill templates out there
alright let's see I see Karthik's got a
lot of these questions here that's good
yeah if you make changes to the
interaction model you do need to rebuild
the interaction model so anytime you
make a change to the interaction model
you do need to rebuild it
so I know it's hard to debug lambda
functions yes so so on debugging it
depends on where you are in the testing
so you can debug using just regular unit
testing so mocha or chai if you're
familiar with those with with JavaScript
or node to do a lot of the debugging and
then the CLI also provides a simulate
interface that you can use to to test
the skill but when it actually gets to
to voice testing that's yeah you'll have
to walk through that but most of most of
the testing can be automated and there's
some and I'll get into this later on but
there's some good tools out there be
smoking tools to help with testing and
test automation and I'll mention those
later on in the stream on another day
any other questions before we wrap it up
for today let me see
okay okay I think that's some I think
that's got most of the questions there
so we're gonna we're gonna make this our
stopping point for today and then
tomorrow what we'll do is we'll pick up
by talking in more detail about the
skill that we're going to build for the
next four days and start working on that
code so hopefully I'll see you guys back
tomorrow if you have any questions you
can go ahead and post them here I'll
I'll keep an eye out on this for the
next few minutes to answer any questions
if you have those but if not I will
catch you again tomorrow and thanks
thanks so much